RETO MEIER: Good afternoon,
everyone, and welcome to
Google Developers Live.
My name's Reto Meier.
I'm the tech lead
for the Android
developer relations team.
And today, I have the very great
pleasure of interviewing
Hiroshi Lockheimer, VP of
engineering for Android, and
Hugo Barra, VP of product
for Android.
So congratulations on a great
keynote yesterday--
a lot of really exciting
news for
developers that we all heard.
I think probably the most
exciting thing which
developers have been talking
about to me is the new Android
Studio IDE.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about what meditated
those changes?
Why have we gone in this
direction, and what's the
future there?
HUGO BARRA: So as we said
yesterday, we're listening.
This is one of the most common
pieces of feedback that we get
from developers is that they
want more options.
There's a lot of people who
love Eclipse and will be
Eclipse die hard fans for
the rest of time.
But there are people who
want different options.
There are people using IntelliJ
already in the community.
So we thought, why don't we join
forces with JetBrains,
and starting from their
community edition product,
which is open source, can we
build something that's even
more customized to Android
developers?
And I think we're there with
this early preview.
But there's so much
more to come.
RETO MEIER: It's a really
exciting time.
I think from a developer
perspective, it's great to
have this whole suite of tools
that we can use, depending on
whatever your preference is.
So it will be exciting to see
how that continues on.
One thing which we get tend to
get asked a lot-- and it would
be interesting to get your
opinion on this-- is, do you
think we're ever going to get
to a point where we can all
sit down with an Android device
to do our Android app
developments?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Self-targeting?
RETO MEIER: Yes.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Like being
able to compile on the device.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
On the device.
So open up your Android, start
writing some code, deploy it
to yourself.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah, that
would be a cool feature.
What do you think?
HUGO BARRA: That would
be pretty cool.
It's a hell of a project.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: I want
to see people doing that,
writing some code.
Yeah, that would be cool.
RETO MEIER: That's always
his excuse, right?
You want to give him
a real computer.
He only gets the tablet.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: It's
very Inception-esque.
RETO MEIER: So one of the other
big announcements which
is really exciting-- slightly
less developer focused, but I
think a lot of interest to a lot
of people-- is the music
on demand, or Music
All Access, if I
remember the name.
So I got to ask, what is
your seed for your
current radio stations?
What track is generating
your radio?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Mumford
and Sons for me right now.
I'm kind of into
them right now.
I don't know about you.
Some sort of Brazilian
bossa nova thing?
HUGO BARRA: I have several
different music
personalities in one.
RETO MEIER: What's your
developer personality?
When you sit back and you start
writing out some code,
what do you put on then?
HUGO BARRA: I would say
probably Daft Punk.
Definitely that would
be my seed.
And yesterday, I started
a radio station with
Supertramp's "Dreamer." It's
a little weird, right?
RETO MEIER: Keeping it real.
I was pleased they had Daft
Punk playing in my session
room before I went
up on stage.
It was kind of the perfect
way to start.
HUGO BARRA: Daft Punk seems to
be an omnipresent theme here
at I/O.
RETO MEIER: It's hard to
get away from, yeah.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
What's your seed?
RETO MEIER: It's Daft Punk--
the Daft Punk track, "Get
Lucky." I'm all
about that right now.
Perfect.
So again, we heard a lot of
really impressive numbers
around Android's growth.
It seems like it's all really
exploded over the
last couple of years.
People are asking me,
what is the future?
How does the next phase
of Android growth
and development look?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: You
want me to handle it.
OK.
Well, I think we can talk
about device growth, the
number of devices and
things like that.
But really what we want to focus
on is business growth,
the opportunities for the
developers out there.
So as you saw today, or
yesterday, I guess--
and today and tomorrow--
RETO MEIER: All week.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
All week, yeah.
Our focus is going to be around
how to make developers
more efficient.
This goes back to your first
question about why are we
doing an IDE.
Well, we want you to be more
efficient and more tailored
tools for you.
And we want you to be more
efficient so that you can run
a more efficient business
and things like that.
So a lot of what we do--
Google Play services, also
similar things, bringing the
power of Google into
your application--
it's all about that.
Making developers more
productive, making it a
fruitful business
for everyone.
I think that's where the
growth is going to be.
RETO MEIER: Very nice.
And it happens that tomorrow
is all about business.
All the Google Play sessions are
going to be all tomorrow.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
That's cool.
RETO MEIER: There should be some
really exciting stuff for
[INAUDIBLE].
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: By the way,
I was really excited by
the developer console stuff that
Elie showed yesterday.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely, yeah.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: That stuff
is really cool-- the
translations, and the staged
rollouts, and all that stuff.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, it's been
really impressive
working with that team.
Because we're on developer
relations, we're right on that
cutting edge.
And to see Elie and her team
come in and really engage with
developers and find out,
what do they want?
Let them get yelled at for a
little while instead of me.
It's kind of nice.
They actually can do something
about it, which is fantastic.
So it's really exciting.
HUGO BARRA: How do you feel
about all the things that
you've been asking us to do
for the last three years
suddenly starting to
come to fruition?
RETO MEIER: It's kind of nice.
HUGO BARRA: You're going
to have to come up
with some new ones.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely, yeah.
And that's why we've got
Office Hours upstairs.
It's been great to finally be
able to talk to some of the
people who have come to I/O year
after year and are asking
us these things.
And we can finally say, well,
yeah, actually we launched it.
What else do you want?
Changes the conversation.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: What
else do people want?
RETO MEIER: What else
do people want?
They want all kinds of things.
I think it's really more
along the same lines.
I think people want to have
richer tools, particularly
around design.
I think that's one of the most
exciting elements of Android
right now, and mobile, and
computing in general, is
trying to move beyond apps which
do what you want them to
do to apps which are delightful
and create this
experience that people
really love.
Which leads me into
another question.
What are some of the Android
apps that you guys love from a
design perspective?
We have design all
afternoon today.
We're talking about design,
telling people what they
should be doing.
Do you have any apps that you've
been playing with which
really encapsulate that spirit
of design that you'd
like to call out?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: All the apps
that I'm using right now
are pre-release stuff that I'm
really excited about, but I
probably shouldn't say.
I'll get in trouble.
I'm really excited about
a lot of the designs
that are coming up.
Existing apps, I don't know.
You're a big app fan.
RETO MEIER: You've always got
the cool stuff, Hugo.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
HUGO BARRA: I'm a pretty
big fan of Currents.
I'm a pretty big fan of
the new music app
with the new design.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Yeah, All Access?
Yeah, absolutely.
HUGO BARRA: I'm a pretty big fan
of Hangouts, because it's
very focused on just very quick
messaging, and things
get out of the way.
But it still has some cool
features like the parallax
when you slide the compose
panel over the
conversation list.
But Play Store is my
current number one.
I'm actually completely in love
with the new Play Store
experience, particularly on
my Nexus 7, actually.
RETO MEIER: They've done a
really great job there.
You mentioned the
Nexus 7 as well.
So I think tablets are something
which represent a
huge opportunity, I think,
for developers.
Are there any tips that you
guys would suggest, as big
tablet users, for developers who
are just sort of starting
to make that transition into
building apps for tablets--
sort of guidance that you might
want to suggest to them?
HUGO BARRA: Well, I would
say, first of
all, look at the data.
It's pretty clear to everyone
now that Android tablets are
in a major tear.
If you look at the data that
we've released, the data that
comes from third parties,
it's pretty insane.
And the tablet explosion,
curiously, is not US-centric,
like the initial smartphone
explosion was.
It's actually happening
all over the world.
So as a developer, I would think
very carefully about the
markets that I could
go into first.
But there are markets like
Brazil, Mexico, Indonesia,
where more than 50% of the
tablets that are sold, from
what we hear, are
Android tablets.
So clearly, these are
exploding markets.
And in these countries, what's
really interesting is that a
tablet is actually sometimes
the only computer that a
person has.
It's actually very common.
So I think there's a lot of
opportunity there that
developers aren't yet attuned
to, and which I think they
should take a closer look at.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: And really,
tactically, I think
following the tablet design
guidelines, you saw yesterday
that we're starting to do some
stuff with that now, with the
targeting where all apps
are designed for
tablets in Play Store.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RETO MEIER: You do
the right thing.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Exactly.
So following those guidelines
actually has some merit now.
There's some benefit to you.
RETO MEIER: Can actually
see it.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Yeah, exactly.
So I think that's a really
tactical thing that developers
should start doing.
RETO MEIER: So the transition
has been from more and more
powerful smartphones to we've
started to see tablets.
So do you think we've kind of
started to plateau now in
terms of that rapid growth
around mobile technology?
Or do you think there's
still more to come?
Are we going to see new
features in chip sets?
sorts of devices?
Or are we kind of done now we
got phones and tablets?
What do you think?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: I
think we're just at
the beginning, honestly.
I'm excited about
all the sensors
that could be in your--
I think Larry talked about
this yesterday, right?
All the sensors that could be
combined and put into phones
in a more battery
efficient way.
New kinds of use cases that we
haven't even imagined yet.
I don't know what they are.
That's Hugo's job to figure
this stuff out.
HUGO BARRA: You get
the easy job.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: I think
we're just getting started.
HUGO BARRA: We're just
getting started.
Sundar opened with some cool
lines yesterday in his keynote
speech where he was talking
about 900 million Android
devices activated, but then 7
billion people in the world.
And you look at markets that
are growing so quick, like
India for example.
He didn't specifically break out
India, but India has less
than 2% of penetration from
an Android perspective.
So less than 2 out of
maybe 100 people
actually have an Android.
And it's a booming economy, so
it's obviously clear that that
market is going to do so well.
So we haven't even scratched
the surface I think is
probably the way to look at it
from the point of view of
growth worldwide.
So I really think that there's
a lot more to come.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah,
there's growth.
But there's also, I think,
technically just so much more
that could happen.
Even just a few years ago, you
couldn't have imagined some of
the things we're doing today.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
I remember when you guys put
a barometer into the zoo.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Yeah,
that's right.
RETO MEIER: That's
interesting.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Exactly.
RETO MEIER: So seeing what
developers can come up with
more newer sensors.
Particularly some of the stuff
around location has been
really, really exciting.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Yeah, exactly.
And the Google Play services,
those APIs, the location APIs
that Hugo talked about.
RETO MEIER: So I think we're
just about ready to wrap up.
So I wanted to ask you, flip it
around, go the other way.
So we're talking about
the future.
Android's been around for about
5 years now, thousands
of devices.
What's your all time
sentimental
favorite Android device?
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: For me, it's
got to be the G1, because
that's what started it all.
That's old school, but that's
what really started it.
And it had that wacky fold
out display, which was a
real pain to build.
But HTC did a great
job, I think.
And just a lot of sentimental
value for me.
I don't know about you.
HUGO BARRA: For me, it's
got to be the Droid.
Droid.
Because that's when we came
out with voice search and
turn-by-turn navigation and
all those cool things in a
really, really big way.
So I think to me, that was the
big water divider from an
adoption perspective.
RETO MEIER: I remember when we
were dogfooding the Droid.
So you had 100 people on the
floor in building 44, and
every two seconds,
Droid, Droid.
Yeah.
And for me, it was the same--
the Droid and the Nexus 1.
Because I gave away a bunch of
Nexus 1s at that point to
developers to help get
them kick started.
And so yeah, that has a special
place in my heart.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
That's cool.
RETO MEIER: Well, thank you guys
very much for taking time
out of your busy schedules
to chat to us on Google
Developers Live.
Congratulations again,
and good luck for
Android in the future.
HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER: Thank you.
Likewise.
HUGO BARRA: Thanks
for having us.
RETO MEIER: Thank you.